I think it's
always important for marketing that I
turn around and say where do I come from and what
exactly is going on? We want to
remain unique, we're not
interchangeable and I think that's a
huge advantage
I still have a skin cream or something like that, it
's not comparable and I think it's
really a gift,
but it's clear that the SAS
is special for someone in Brazil or
someone in the USA who does
n't have a relationship yet  also
invited and or I'll say we
'll go there too, so I'll say
I'll go to the Oktoberfest in Blumenau in Brazil, of course I'll also go
with the voxclub or really, of course,
I was also at the Wacken but I'm very
welcome to the noodle
OMR Podcast today premieres the first podcast
from Rheinberg in the Ruhr area and
we are here in the headquarters of Underberg,
the spirits brand of the
historic company. I have just been
given a tour and we will
talk about it. There is really a lot of
history and
I have the
owner, Christian Undererberg
as a guest hello Mrs. undererberg greetings
I'm happy but the owner is my
husband and I'm assigned to him and I
think it's nice for 60 years yes
okay okay but already the owner
family let's say thank you
agreed I'm having
a big tour here right now  When did it start
with unberg? We are 177
years old and always in family hands and
always from one generation to the next,
so we are very capable of grandchildren and
my husband is already a grandchild
if you look backwards, yes, exactly,
so they are then  now together with her husband
the fourth generation yes
robertine the F and the sixth is coming soon
exactly exactly okay and of course the company
has a very busy
history it started but so how did
you come up with the idea how did people come up with the idea back then  to
found or invent a spirit,
yes, the founder of the founder
was very busy, learned
in Holland and other countries
and was not impressed, as he
was in the Netherlands, that he found drinks
with an elixir and an elixir for
that  Word is also nice because it then
shows again that it does something good,
but it was mixed very differently
and this gave
rise to his desire to develop a product that was always of the
same quality because that's
how they could do it, they
could do it wonderfully  so much of it and so
much of it depending on how it
had to be with the money and then he wanted to
create a, let's say, trustworthy product
by sempa idem the gene that
always has the same quality, not always the
same recipe and but you there  Came up with
the idea obviously it's still
a bitter stomach to this day that's what they say
about it no so yes yes we're not a liör
because we don't have any sugar but would
you say that it's delicious I've
had different experiences so
how I met my husband
I was still very
young at the time and I didn't know the product
yet, so I said I think
it's very nice, but the product would take
some getting used to and I have to
say, and that's what happens to a lot of people, so
I said in between
two three drinks and you know
what to expect what you hear when you drink
then you remember and then there are
all these fans that we also have, we really have all these
capsule collectors who think of our product with great joy
when they come in  The
various occasions are now
sold undererberg in over 100 countries in
over 100 countries in the world, yes, okay,
but the journey started in such a way that
someone invented it, inspired by the port of
Holland, of simply wanting to have the same quality
and also somehow something
healthy  Understanding so and
then g about which it has been
proven that all proteins are digested twice as
quickly in the lower part and not that is
not the same as alcohol. I
once did a distillation course
that also digests fat.
Everyone knows that if you are very fat  Once you've
eaten you can also drink a schnapps
and do something more and
the grandparents in particular often pass this experience on to the others.
They don't give a bit of an
overview of all these
different terms. There are
such schnapps that it's not part of it  No,
that's colloquially schnapps,
so it's not exactly here in the Uhrü region.
Let's have a quick drink or a
schnapps or something like that. That's colloquial,
but that's not a definition. I'll tell you
how you define a brand.
Liqueur is always with sugar, so we
have  Yes, there are also liqueurs in our house,
so when I think of P minignon
or something like that or now the aperitif or
now our new herptini has a
little bit but what kind of sugar
depends on whether it is honey or achon syrup
or whatever our syrups have
of course  Sugar from rimerschmidt and and
and how big was the company when you
got to know the company 60 years ago, so
I can only say that it was much smaller, but now
I have to say no, my husband was
the one, so when we got married it was
a
mono-product company
Unterberg and there was also a
conversational stress like my husband said
he wanted to do bohekamp because he then
came onto the market with mabone, who then
marketed something below the price entry limit and then he said no,
that's strategic now but it's
no longer so friendly  and then
we have, we also do and other
products with sugar or Hubertus
Drops. Young people in particular know
a lot about them, they build little towers and
make it really fun, which
are also low-grade for young people,
um but that's not all  among the
names underberch only underberch has the
name unterweg they are now called the
same as the product in sof that is quite
but yes
through marriage but still so the company
was significantly smaller than today yes
no no and it was
sometimes bigger like that  It would be
an exciting journey, yes, no, and
I think that's the case from the entrepreneurial side and that
applies to me because I'm also a
family of entrepreneurs. It's actually a
trademark of real
entrepreneurs. They always have to readjust
themselves and we're
currently going through the
transformation process as I have to  yes,
always with questions, I still do the
right thing, I still meet the spirit of the times,
I am still for my consumers or
my lovers, I am still current and
my husband has in our time
Schlumberger also
took over this winery, the oldest
winery in Austria  and then
we also had trading houses with wine and
so on and one day he said now
the whole world is actually doing it
like a bmme, people have
more and more knowledge and compare and
buy more from winemakers and then he
really made the cut and has  This
whole corner was cut off as a result of which
employees were gone and there were a lot of them
in Germany now only
and also the trading houses with eensch
and that was like we always
said in the house or I then also had
become a heavy tanker they have to
yes then always and then I like to come to
my favorite word which would be important to me
for
our conversation today systems. They
always have to look at how long a
system can be resilient and when does a system fall apart
because sometimes they can no
longer manage it due to their competence  from
the employees of the
market requirements there are many
parameters where you then
have to readjust yourself and I think these
are the questions that we have today too,
we have the questions again today yes
our energyf I won't even
mention it for long  I can't
go on like this, since I'm now very
sustainably oriented or we're all sustainably oriented in our house
and there's a new
trend, so they're the best
example with social media, AI
and chatbots and so on
I have to say what does this do to
our consumers, what does this do to the
Millennials, what does this do to us and since
as a social worker I always work from a
human
perspective, I believe that it is very important
to explain what a system is and
I have that in mind  learned a lot about biology
or in our research in
Tyrol a system falls apart when it
gets too big, which is why they also have the
Rusty Belt in America where the
car industry has become so big that
it was partly destroyed and
that's where you have to go now  Be
careful again, I don't want to
name any names which companies have
reached a limit somewhere, that's true too, but
Underberg had reached a limit so
it was over 1000 people and now
we're currently back at 200,
yes that was a real cut that was the
hardest  Time this phase no not at all no
we earn something here and there something
no I can't
say that anymore just
the forces are shifting too I think it's much more
what what what what are the possibilities
of the individual in the system too  to do or
how far yes or how far
otherwise you lose sight of your own your own hero
so D let's
talk a bit about the Unterberg system because
in the end it's these wrapped brows
mostly straw paper straw paper
wrapped little bottle right here there are
a few standing around with
By the way, I learned to wrap the Unterberg sticker on it
because the
roof is so hygienic that
many people drink
directly from the bottle and so there is
a bit of hygiene that's why the
paper around it is
produced here, so to speak, the herbs
are delivered here and then it is
Prepared here in large cauldrons, these
are herbs from 43 countries around the world that are
delivered, okay, but that means
that the products come
here, um, near Duburg and
then they are bottled here
and something like that. Here is the
core  in this respect because the recipe
is mixed here and only the family does it, so
family the recipe is the
big secret but so the
added value is so here it is
produced here it is bottled and then it
is sold, above all to the
trade or yes no again  Wait a moment
here it goes from here it goes
from here according to the secret area it goes from
here now it used to go to
Berlin it goes to Rüdesheim where
we now have the bottling into the
small bottles and and then it
all starts  Trade or, above
all, gastronomy, who is it for?
Trade, of course, more of
course Gastronomy is always
actually our preparer and
we are very connected to the gastronomy
right down to the bartenders and so on,
but
I would say that they make the big sales
with trade trade is the
focus and that's why I think they're really good for
me. I'm
very lucky with the professional
management of the team,
these conversations are these
price negotiations, they're
not funny at all, so I think
I regret every one of them  Sometimes and so much and
I can't drink them how
much Diemer have to negotiate because of the
length of time s don't eat part of the
negotiations or used to be yes
no, I'm no longer in the operating room,
I've done h in the operating room for 20 years
or something like that, yes, but it was a while ago and
then I got sick and
then I went out, but
corporate culture is simply my
topic and that of my daughter and
it goes on like that, okay, so that means
a little bit of value creation is
understood, it's understood here  produced
bottled really rude in in Rüdesheim
yes Asbach which belongs to us that's exactly what
I wanted to say they also bought some things
so Astbach ancient I know from
the TV from before um that's all
part of the empire yes the funny thing is
we had to come from Ber  or we would
have my father-in-law, I have to
say now to be fair, in order to
show the commitment, he said back then that
we have to make Berlin strong politically
and then the time of change came and
then at some point we
thought about yes, then we'll
leave Berlin  because all of a sudden our
company property was located next to
Tetrapack and friends, um, it was much too
valuable, so it was really
much more suitable for another development,
like us with our, well,
production corners, where we celebrated the beautiful
festival with wild boars
and brass instruments, wonderful and  Yes, really,
we, the whole team, the women
cooked, the men sang,
God was full, well anyway, and then I went
to Asbach on a
weekend with the nuns upstairs, with whom
I have a nice relationship, and
then I heard someone hammering at Asbach
Knocked on that Saturday and then
I thought oh there is, but either someone was
busy or someone had no
business there, I went there and then
said man, the property is
actually big enough, why don't we build
here, aha, okay, that's
fun, what's the hesitation?  the story
with her husband, she is already 60 years old, so
to speak, the relationship but when did
they officially join the company
81 after my husband paid off the last cousin
then he had 100% so he had
two thirds because his partner uncle
had left him his third so there
My father-in-law was the two
little ones who were very close and
then he had
the tribe undererberg Emel
undererberg had two thirds and then there was
the tribe dr karlunderberg
who had a third and my
husband just paid off the cousin so that
's the idea  always consolidating that
means keeping the share in the nuclear family
why why is important yes
because there are two models some
are successful because they are always
managed by others and then
mammoth think of Haniel so
I think they are  Now it's not over 1000
and that's a
different number in terms of taxes and we're also small,
we're also small bottles of a small
company, so I read up on EUR 140 million
last year,
I confessed that somewhere,
yes 145 but plus  29
million with the new one,
yes, that's exactly what I wanted to ask, like
after the sales and the
number of employees, so to speak,
fell sharply for a few years, you have
the
feeling that maybe there are
difficult times ahead of you, then at
some point the turnaround was
initiated  They did that, yes,
of course, a lot of things came together. Something like that
is multifunctional, it can't be
explained causally, but
one thing is certainly the fact that the
former management figures speak my
husband and and Mr. Mocken, that they were
also older in terms of age. Mr. Mocken
also has one  own business and
my husband also became sicker and then yes
and my daughter, my son-in-law and
I stayed over and then
we decided to turn around in the
sense of decided it's good but we
did it yes no I believe
in people now comes  Then of
course that's where I come into play. Unfortunately, I now have to
say that I believe that you
can only run a company really well
if the people fit together and it
had to be. Mr. Mempel was already
there for a few years and had
proven himself and is a great salesman
yes and then Mr. Söke, whom you
met, had to be
looked for and
I always put a lot of effort into
looking for everyone to see whether the
person fits our culture but
also fits the team because I believe in the team very much
and I believe  It is very
important that the match
somehow fits and you have
really arrived in the family when the
secret is transferred to you again
and mixed that is Jaag guarded
like the Coca-Cola formula of course um
Coca-Cola I would now
claim slim at Coca-Cola I do
n't know exactly for us I can
vouch for the fact that it is so I got it
from my mother-in-law because my
father-in-law had already passed away
and my husband was doing other things so
he came every now and then and then I  I've been
doing this for a lot of time and
now the main focus is on rubertine with
the clergy to preserve the recipe.
Say no no, we do it by hand, oh
they must have fun, we look
like we come from somewhere else,
it's not a clean job, craftsmen  They
have it, they mix it themselves
by hand, of course, oh okay, okay, yes, we
are craftsmen, I
said put the hood on then I said to mine,
I think I would like to have stim, but they
sell millions of liters one to
one and still F people are
the ones who  They get the mix
right, so they have their daughter, two
clergymen from nearby here who are
not one was from Austria who
unfortunately passed away. Father Norbert
unfortunately died, the sister from
Austria and now we have we
have three clergymen okay and then
come  and three my husband is
still there, of course he has his head
for the recipe, my Robertino doesn't,
but you can't mix anymore, no, you do
n't need it either, he can
add it, check whether the others are
doing it correctly, I'll say you can do that
too  not always everyone who how much do
you have to put together to
produce 100 million liters that
is physical work they get a
good breakfast but are now 83 years
old yes and they how many times a week or
no I no I say that anyway  not
but I say the main focus is that
Robertine's daughter is now doing it and I'm
clear and she is
the more or the only one we are the
herb witches for the entire
production yes and how is it but and the
clergy have to learn that first  It's
all just up here, but is she
active every day? No no, we do it, yes, they also have it with
the cellar master, they also
heard that there are still
herb masters
It's
not wet, but I won't tell you
which herbs are included,
no, they're all coded, that's
all at least agatee
Christi, okay, yes, of course, you always have to fine-tune it
a little bit, and you'll have to do that again and again
Everything was only handed over verbally, there
is no document really right mm
I also had my friend the abbot
and I said so Stefan it works
but you do
n't have it memorized yet then we repeat it so
the mixture which herbs
which which
Shares of a real trust person, i.e.
daughter or clergy, they bring
in in order to be able to produce this product,
yes, and the clergy
come several times a year,
of course, and then
they mix and then it's hand work,
but I also have a strong one
Daughter, she can handle it well, she has
the
fitness, it's not a bit
dangerous in this day and age to
have so few people who
have that in mind and then if
something happens then it's gone, we do
n't travel together, so now  If
possible, no, so I'll say I
used to, thanks to them. We have four
children and I also had two from
my brother. We always
traveled with the children separately,
one three here, one three there or so that
can also be the case  If you
think about it a bit, you can sort it out and the
spiritual lives in their monasteries
or in their communities or something like that and
you simply spoke to them according to the
person, well they
were always trusting
friends, I saw it here,
there's a house like that  It
was clear to me that commitments are mixed, but I
now only five people are
allowed to do crafts in there
and then it's different streetsit
is then, so to speak, the mass production
there W but the herbs, so to speak, are already
distilled, so to speak, right there is
the distillation and everything
Seal everything covered, everything has to
imagine how many millions of liters
are needed to get to 100 almost
150 million sales in the end, so
you can't do that with just a few
couples, no, and that's what keeps
us awake or but it's the
history  the film is also incredibly
important, if you experience it like that, the
house is also a museum somewhere for,
say, glasses for the history of
the company for a bit, it's
culture, it's culture, they
have to think that the next generation
has to empathize again  which has
actually happened before and I
think it's always important for marketing
that I say that I
turn around and say where do I come from and what
's going on now? We want to
remain unique, we're not
interchangeable and I think that's one
huge advantage, I know something like that if
I still have a skin cream or something like that, it
's not comparable and I think it
's really a gift
but it's clear that the SAS is special
now someone in Brazil or someone in the
USA has it now  No
relationship yet, they're also
invited and or I say we
'll go there too, so I'll say
I'll go to the Oktoberfest in Blumenau in Brazil, of course I'll go
there with voxclub or of course, I was
at Wacken too but I'm  such a
noodle so they are also so you
say of course the
brand wearer always green costume and, so to speak, their
own brand yes yes but
I have to say that it only
increased green was because I
was very connected to nature and was always
my favorite color  From your point of view, how important is
the marketing behind the whole success story
because I mean there are also
rooms here where the
airships used to be, Underberg was always
on top of those zeppelins and
marketing is also very important and
infinitely important  Because on the
one hand we want to be authentic
and not some kind of green washing or
something like that, on the other hand you have to
explain it, the generations are growing
and then I have to
find the key again as to how I
actually respond to these consumer needs
It's actually difficult to
keep such an old brand alive, it
has to stay alive and
I actually have
a lot of sense for liveliness. I think it's actually
fun. Are they inspired by what
the Jägermeister branch does because they
've done it that way too  a
different product but still one,
they are now
significantly bigger, I GL, they make over
a billion in sales, so if
you look at it, well, we do
n't have any feelings of competition with them.
I really have to say, we
only look at it to a limited extent  It's just with
sugar and liqueur and other reasons, how much does a
bottle of Underberg cost in stores
if I have one of those now, then make
a €o that's from to EF not so
that's an approximate depending on how it's
traded  1€ a
bottle yes yes so and and and then the
production costs 50 cents or
something like that the production of the bottle yes I'll tell you that
[laughter]
okay I'll stay out of it okay but in the
end it's because he should do it  It's supposed to
improve so in that I
only have old numbers in my head but in the
end it's of course about
the company. You have to somehow
earn a certain amount of money so that you
can afford it 100% of course
every company has to earn money
and that's it  We really have to
right now I have to say
I'm very irritated by what's going on politically,
we don't want to get involved in politics now,
but I have to earn
money first before I can become social,
so that's
just the way it is  can give if the
company is healthy Underberg has
always donated hugely so what I
could do here now is a quiz
from the Underberg bathroom to church windows
to paths, the vulture knows something or we do
too and I have nuns and
all sorts of things but I have to say  It has
to be earned first and the
order some people are no longer really in the
swing of things because I say there are
limits somewhere they are no longer healthy they have
also experienced it so I think at least
you can read a little bit that there
were also tough years where the firmer
The W probably didn't earn anything for a few years and then
I can't say I can't distribute it with a
big shovel.
Carnival was that for them so that
you felt that you were once in fear
I'll soon make a distinction between
fear and fear because I think that's
how fear is going around at the moment and it irritates
me a lot. I notice that again and again
in conversations. Fear is something diffuse and
fear is something emotional and with that
I push my own mood down
and  When it's still pretty good
I get into a lot of brooding and brooding is a
recycling of negative thoughts without
a solution. Fear is like in
nature when I know something, when the
lion comes towards me I just have to be
afraid and have to say I need
a tree like that  or what if I
really if here
is responsible and this kind of history um
really on the back so to speak
and then you suddenly see man
here we are making losses it is getting tight it is
getting tight then you have a lot of
fear  yes and then you get creative
so for me it's generally when it
gets tight somewhere that's why I say tight when it gets
tight that you say
escape or hold your ground somewhere are the two
I've done behavioral research
so in field research escape or
hold out in the wild  Also and you
can always say to yourself, I'm going out
of business or I'm going to go
one step further or I'm going to do something
new, there are lots of options, what W so
the new things where you said
now a new idea we have them out
this turned out of the negative spiral
there yes there I have to
start with my husband who found yes he
found then after the mono product
think about what distribution he
has set up we have that
too I have that somewhere we have 15 eye products
at the moment and  45 third brands, all the
contacts, all these networks and
I was like, we're a small
shop, but one of the
whiskey people Emil said, everyone
in the industry knows you, so of the big ones there
were all the big ones, we have them
too  so big FIV and so on and that's they have to be
present there too, there are
these networks within themselves and my
husband, for example, has been very committed
to European issues and alcohol
and so on
Others push
that as a company but
say a two very specifically like me that
then via networks new
people in the sales department were convinced. Man was
the one who went to me Taxa
and I'm still with them today, I don't know what
I'm going to the chersy  Flower Show
or 40 on their boat they have
yes they are now in ATH Taxa is a dealer in yes
they have been selling for a long time but
with Taxa there is a family with Taxa
like us and there were two brothers and they are
both still alive and
We still have the most cordial contacts with them
and they have bought larger quantities
when things got tight,
no, with them, no, we
represented their products and then
something got stuck there again and as a result this whole
distribution, okay, actually,
to solve the problems, new entire
distribution branches  which were then, let's say,
a different business and they
weren't wine and champagne but
they were spirits again. There was
also the idea of
selling the company. That's what you're asked from outside.
That's of course the people who
are  yes, always hungry, people come up to
you and say hey, that's something
unique and that would be interesting
and then you can say yes or no, yes,
that they would say yes, that
was once an issue, no, that wasn't an issue until
now  not so even if
someone comes now, an investor, then you do
n't sit in the evening between saying, thinks about it,
people should win, but now it's starting to get
difficult and a
lot of them have done that, look who's left of the
industry as a
family business, there are a lot of them  made
and I also
understand that you can read about
who no longer exists, I wo
n't name them now, okay, but who is who who is who
is still such an independent
spirits family, yes, we
just called them a jgermeister,
exactly, but there are many more
Not either or at least there are
some but different sizes and
I think that's right. I'm
more in favor of there being competition. Take a look
despite being a bit jealous and
other
areas. Gin has done incredibly well
in the last few years
Huge successes, I think whiskey has
also experienced a huge run in the
last decade or so, um, and then
you think, man, why is
n't our area
similar? I have to
say, we discussed that too,
apart from Heinrich,
we had him in our portfolio ourselves
We do it or we do
n't do it and I have to say that
you also have to look at the market power and
how much marketing costs a
big house can put behind it. Does that add too much to it in
an ME2 project
?  Um, then the
marketing people come and then we sit
down in a big circle and say one way or
another and
I have to laugh. I used to
run our farm. I
actually feel that over the long
haul, sometimes the brown
drinks are on top  and sometimes the white ones used to be, sometimes
the pork prices are high, sometimes
the cattle prices are high, there are
always waves in the market and you always have to look,
the market is already very ripe, so the
2006 whiskey or gin is now
more yes  I don't want to be or
vodka but they've also
done cleverer things like that,
sometimes with celebrities from George
cloney, they suddenly have their own gin or something like that.
There are a lot of different actors
who suddenly stand up for brands like that
or somehow
belong to them  Is there such a consideration too
or or say we have a lot of fans
we have an awful lot of fans but
we we I'll say now I always have
the opinion in my ear like the one from
before
and they just need to
do something wrong once and then that's it  The thing with the
product is no longer at cluni, he
's old enough. I hope and get married
now that nothing too big will
happen, but we have so many fans
that we've actually found them. I'll
say that it really goes from
Gottschall to Isabel Wert  We
also have one of those,
all Unterberg fans and these, the
Fantastic Four, the whole groups
or am and amart, I
just told the ladies about von Wacken, I
visited them there, they're all there, we got a
truck
I was with the
guys because I was also
the yes, the story was that the
founder of the snowboard brand BURTON
is Jack Burton and he just
called them and said man,
I'm a fan too and after snowbard
descent I always drink like that  an
Underberg and I would like to
do a collaboration like this now, I would like to
produce gladberg snowbards now, yes, it
's so wonderful when they come to us from outside, it
's the most beautiful thing
and that's actually, I would say, an
accolade somewhere that
someone like that comes to us  and
then we expanded on that and I think it
's e.g. what they just say, what's
a moment when you
learn to ski late, first when I was 16 then again
but I really enjoyed skiing, I
also have a nice scar from skiing and
so on  I just think it's so nice, we
're just a drink that
goes all the way from the old to the young,
so here are the students when I
was here recently, I was in Leipzig,
it's there again, we said we're
all drinking underberch again now or or
ours  They call Hubertus the Hubi
or hupsi or have their
own names and that's
funny, it's actually also W that they
once advised Angela Merkel, yes, I
was on the Sustainability Council and they're
co-opted. I don't even know who
kindly recommended me there  and
I thought that was a very early idea of ​​hers,
that was in the early 2000s,
um, and we were totally mixed, so I'll
say all the parties or
scientists, total mix, about 15
people, and um, my husband and I have
the biggest environmental project  of the Alps was
initiated very early on and that's why
I stand by the fact that we are hunters
because I think we also have to
handle nature and we are experiencing right
now that some things are too much and some
too little, that we have too many neo-zones,
i.e. animal and plant species  that do
n't actually belong here and
we dealt with these things very
early on and were also in
the throes of adversity, so now in the
case in Austria in Tyrol and that's how
Mrs. Merkel came up with them and that's how
I think it is  My explanation is the
other way around, but I have
always been active in the protection of monuments. I have been
in the monument hut for 19 years, so
that is also a preservation, um, and
with new methods, for example acid
rain at the time or something like that, what did that do to the cathedral
in Xanten or something like that  It was
multi-pronged and there's
one piece of advice or something like that on
the topic where they say that I
really
had an impression or an effect,
um I think first of all you learned the
discourse very well because there were some people
who were completely against it  the yacht
until I explained what we do
and what responsibility we
feel. By the way, I worked on international ethical rules for the
International Hunting Council,
so
the advice given to Ms. Merkel
was also about hunting and then not about
nature  She is a
natural scientist herself and she was
very early on about it back then and that
is what I regret today that
it took 20 years for the word
sustainability to even land
and I said it to the State Secretary at the time, I
can
Lieschen  Müller and his friend Anton
don't understand a word
like sustainability at all and since I only
grew up in the Ruhr area, I
said we have to find something emotional, something
that is touching and
everyone can think of grandchildren and in ability the
WD is capable of being grandchildren and yes and  I did
n't want that either. Well, we
did a few later and then I did
these. I think that suits me. I
trained apprentices
in housekeeping for 40 years, but I
worked with people and
I believe that will continue to be the case in the future
The most important thing is that we
take people with us so that they can
cope with the new influences
and then they don't have
these diffuse fears, but that they
are also strong for it and that was
very interesting because everyone, I'll say
the energy people  Look at things
differently like those who are only conservationists
and not and the ideologues
I don't need them anyway so they do
n't just have their opinion and no
other, that's a bit difficult for me
and that was very exciting and
unfortunately I have to leave due to kreps
but  Then Mrs. Merkel just
wrote that I not only
got a diligent card but
also coined the word grandchildable
and, thank God, that was
broken here until earlier by minister thin and the universities in between,
all of them up to
Haniel and because  They were just talking so much about
hunting, they are also there. There is
also an anecdote about the first
German woman with a hunting license. No, that
was definitely after the war. I think
someone did. Journalists are
sometimes a bit generous and that
was certainly meant in a nice way  No, before the
war there were some I was too, but I'm
sure I was the only one in my
course over 50, so back then I was
still, as the saying goes,
no one would
say that today, there have been
attempts like that for a long time  to relaunch the brand,
now after all these years, I found
that interesting, there were also
Underberg bonbons, yes, and I actually regret that,
so there we have it. I have to
say that I still believe
in it
because there is no bonbon for them  Stomach
and for those who don't drink alcohol and
I would like to do it again if
we had time for it because we must have
done something wrong, you do
n't do everything right and my
husband and I have always thrown in a lot of
ideas or  or
I found this idea fascinating
to actually make underberg sweets to
make underberg sweets because
you can also use them with there are still
I we still have a few leftovers we
bought the rest because it
didn't go the way we
imagined it would  The return on
investment wasn't that great, but
I think the idea is still good, so
if someone in the audience
has a great idea, okay, I, I, there
are a few more, we
did a little research, there was also
a herb  Liquor with espresso is
just now available, it's a
limited edition and we had the
courage to do something nice for you, where did
I put it in this
bottle because it's from Martini
and espresso and  That's a total inn,
but a bartender invented it. It
's not our invention, it's
the idea of ​​putting it in the portion bottle.
Now it actually goes
back a bit to the idea of
the founder, so let's say to make it more
standardized  Now it's
new and it's only been
on since September 1st and it was
wonderful back then. I had two brothers who each
had a shop. We're not
making false advertisements and
one of them said that, but I have to
tell you that my brother has Mrs. Unterbech  There's something about it
and I haven't yet because
that was before it officially came in,
it was really cute how it
almost hit each other, that we want to
be the first and they do that in
marketing, a really
classic loyalty campaign, so if you're like that
Collect these bottle caps and
send them in and you get something and so it
's really quite simple, it's actually
like loyalty marketing, no, exactly and
this loyalty is so that
every now and then after a few years there
were questions about whether to
stop it because there is  yes, then the
incentives and so on and then my husband
vetoed it and said no,
it hasn't reached everyone yet
and we have a million returns,
we have such a return rate that
is indescribable W just people
send their their unberg lids back
the lids  But there are also some
recently I met someone who says
I've already collected a few hundred
and I'm still collecting, there
are also people who S what do you get
for a lid like that if you
put it back? You can even look at eBay
Cents as a currency sometimes
people don't have enough money for so and so much.
You can easily check this in our shop
for what how many lids
you need, whether for the porcelain or the
glasses
You put bottles in it like that but there are no more blatant things
about Pepsi. Did you see the
campaign? You could
win a military plane like that if you
collected Pepsi like that. No
military plane, certainly not with us. I
think that would be the wrong merit,
no with us  But it's this
truck that has a lot of cribs and it
's there for restaurateurs who
are extremely unerberg fans who are extremely
excited about all of their possibilities. There
are really big
cars, we're now talking about a
dishwasher or, precisely, a vintage car  Well, there are
also undererbech fans, I have to
say an ambassador, Mr. Schberg, who
even covered his Porsche with undererbch
himself, so we don't do that,
we do that because we said
Porsche, that's what I think now makes him
worry about the restaurant and gastronomy dying  I just
read an article on the way here in England or there
are more than two bars in Germany. There used to be
a lot more of these bars in the country, but now it's
not like that anymore and
I actually think that's a shame we had
a pub culture and the English
have a pub culture so I'll say it
was actually that I went with my
grandmother every now and then I thought it was
great when I was a teenager we'd go and
have a beer, I of course malsbier
and then we ate soleier in
Dortmund Soleier or I say now
or a schnitzel or a meatball
or something like that as a woman you could
also go there because my grandmother was
really another generation
above me and I
actually feel sorry for that because actually the
people in the neighborhood and I think that's what
they're looking for too  again and if I
now from the social worker because I
'm here too in this this is a
European project a botton from
political in the Lieder region these are
four communities together the people
need neighborhood homes who
want the anonymous don't want to
have meeting places but the  The
company's annual economic success is
not incredibly important to him now.
I have the feeling that they are very
relaxed, that everything works, that
has to be positive somehow, but
they don't have that ambition right now, it
always has to grow, it has to get bigger,
no because I  I think there is organic
growth and here I am again
with my biological vocabulary I
think in general I am rather
afraid and there is a shortcoming in
today's world, many young people do
n't allow themselves the time to
reflect from my point of view. Looking back
now  is actually a
healthy development when it goes forward
through a new push and then it has to
be consolidated and there is
too little time for reflection today
and I sometimes feel sorry for that because
everything is Harry from Harry off and quickly quickly
quickly and  here and there
and then I don't get around to
saying, am I actually still doing
it right, can I actually
do it like that, how long do you want to
do it for? So if you're now 83, you're incredibly
fit and young, but you think so, no, no,
I  I'm happy if I can go soon,
I'll clean up, so at some point
the point will come, say well, no, I'm
just up, I'd be happy, I could have
gone but it was
n't that far yet because her daughter has
n't done it yet, no  no, the daughter, the
daughter has been around for 20 years, we
're a team, the third, the grandson
wasn't ready yet, my husband would like to
make it possible for grandchildren to be able to do that too, okay, that
means they're basically waiting until
the grandson, no, that's also
decided  That's okay now,
but until I was 83 it wasn't a problem
to do that, so for you
physically too. I think that's
unusual, yes, I don't know, but
I'm very grateful to heaven. I'm a believer
and I say that must
be the case  Doesn't know
and Kön is not allowed to do it either, so the company
has to stay in the family, that's it, that
's of course an
objective. People
also know that and give two tips on how to
stay fit. I think it's very important to
stay open and  very important
that you stay curious so what did
my one of my daughters is also
extremely curious she said no mom
you are not curious you are
hungry for knowledge then you can now
take what you want no I think
so what is behind me is I ca
n't
change I can't change what's behind me
I can only
do something better forward and I have to
have my activity and my focus on it
and what it says correctly and I
like to do analyzes that's
right and then I just have to look
Does that still fit, because
life takes place between the poles
and I'm afraid that if you
go completely out now that all of a sudden the content will
fall away and then maybe you'll
get older when you don't
have this job anymore, um
no, I have  Yes, so many interests,
I'll be happy when I
can take better care of my relationship again. That's going to be
a bit of a
back burner now.
My husband has his two angelic
friends of mine who will also
do that with me. No,
I'm also social  I'm
still very committed and
no, and my musical side, I used to
paint porcelain, that
's fallow and
I have 12 grandchildren and one and a half great-grandchildren and they
're the grandchildren too. I'm going to
Berg with one of them at the weekend
the penultimate of the
Konstantin FT you go to Tyrol and yes
I'm flying tomorrow I'm flying to
Munich but thanks to your
interview I can't get there so quickly thanks to you,
thank you for doing it like that so
we were allowed to stop by here and
immerse ourselves here at the underterberg
welelt and yes in that it's
really such an ecosystem here and
very nice thank you very much
[applause]
[music]
thank you